Feuer on hold to chat please stay on
hold we will take your phone calls
before mike leach of washington state
and dennis miller join us in our number
three but i turned to my right and I see
one of the most popular athletes in
America over the last quarter century
and I'm not just saying that because
he's sitting to my right or that he's
got a new book that he has written to
celebrate it is a great book called
racing to the finish my story Junior
Dale Earnhardt jr. here in the flesh
good to see you yes you say Mike Leach
yeah yeah he's the we're neighbors in
the keys okay now great way to start
what in the world is it like to be a
neighbor where houses apart but I've ran
into him down there on several places
like Washington scarce I'm just hanging
out okay I'm gonna brew something like
that yeah cool God did you ever have to
borrow something from him knock on the
door no I actually ran into him and he
was with guy he coached the Eagles it's
back in Chip Kelly okay him and chip
were hanging out so he and Chip Keller
hanging out in the keys in the grocery
store parking lot but yeah mike has been
down there a while and so we we both
have houses down there and so we were
kind of always in passing either he's
coming into town and I'm leaving right
that was funny two ships yeah come in so
it's you're like two ships passing in
our number three what's your first
racing memory Dale do you yeah my first
racing memory was being at the dirt
tracks in in around Charlotte North
Carolina there's a Concord Metrolina I
don't know which one I was at but I
remember being at a race I'm probably
six or seven years old and seeing cars
go by I just have this sort of old
memory of watching my dad go by actually
he was running second to Gary Ballou who
was a really really good short track
racer for him up and down the East Coast
and Gary was was bit was Gary won the
race dad run second I just remember that
vividly for whatever reason that little
snapshot and a couple other moments of
you know being at certain races or
racetracks I'm ever being it for
whatever reason I don't know why I
remember being it qualifying for the
Charlotte race I think the world 682 or
83 and those were the early memories for
me did you know for sure this is you
wanted a race I mean is that a door do
you like yeah well when I was a little
boy I was 6 or 7 years old I was a
football player for Halloween and the
same I had this basic plane know number
jersey and the pants the pads the helmet
the shoulder pads I was a I was this
football player for like four years
straight in hat on Halloween until it
never fit anymore and I wanted to be a
Washington [ __ ] I wanted to play
football for the Redskins so as a kid
that was my dream but then you know I
started going to races and understanding
really understanding what my dad was
doing what racing was and immediately
fell in love with that and wanted to
become a racecar driver but I knew you
know I'd seen sons try to follow their
dads into that sport not always easy to
do not it doesn't always work out it's
very hard because if you aren't as good
you catch a lot of flack you know you
get you get beat up pretty bad by by the
fans if you don't measure up and so I
knew it was going to be tough but I
watched my dad win and succeed and
celebrate and it just was amazing I was
I was in all of him and I was kind of
crazy about how people looked at dad
like how dad was treated you know I'm
like man I want to do this people love
what he does people love him mm-hmm
this looks fun and I I've worked a job
you know I worked a real job for a while
and which one my first job was changing
oil I got a speeding ticket and dad said
I had to go get a job to pay for the
lawyer to pay for the ticket to get it
reduced to a muffler ticket or something
like that and improper equipment and so
I got a job pumping gas at Exxon Exxon
station then I worked at a I worked
building racecars at a at a at a shop
for a while I worked as a I worked for
about three or four years in a
dealership changing oil quick lube
twenty nine minutes or less come in I
change your oil change transmission
fluid whatever you wanted yeah I worked
in several jobs in the service
department of the dealership so I worked
if I worked as the assistant to the
engine guy this was the best job if
you're blowed the motor in your car
broke your transmission and you he'd
bring the car in I'd pull the faulty
part the faulty transmission or the
faulty motor and he'd fix it he put the
right one in so I was kind of helping
him you know expedite his job and his
his business and I did that up and I
don't even remember how long but the
racing thing I was racing while I was
doing that job I ran 159 late-model
races at Myrtle Beach Nashville
Tennessee Florence South Carolina all
around in the mid-atlantic region and I
won four of those 159 starts so I didn't
think I was gonna make it you know I
wasn't winning enough races to get a
break and but a break happened you know
I got an opportunity to race a car at
Michigan in the Xfinity series in 97 and
I ran into top ten and race with Dale
Jarrett and a bunch of guys that my dad
raced against my dad was there of those
159 late mile races I ran my dad never
saw one of them no kidding so he never
knew whether I was good bad he never
watched me and went okay yeah he's doing
this he's doing that he knew he had no
clue how to judge me as a racecar driver
only by the stats really so I didn't
think that was gonna be good enough but
he gave me an opportunity of racing one
of his cars and in that day I was able
to showcase some good things and it's
kind of steamrolled from there the rest
being history Dale Earnhardt jr. here
racing to the finish available right now
where books are sold
well I'll say this in terms of what you
said is a little kid you know I want to
do that I want to be as successful as
dad and you saw how is your dad was
successful and I'm and beloved yeah
you've succeeded in both men I mean you
have you know I don't know you're humble
guy you might not want to say you know
okay but you have well I'll say this
again I've always owned the fact that I
gained a ton of race fans pre-packaged
without any you know out really any sure
any
statistics to back it up so I understood
that and I knew that coming in but I
feel like from from the moment I got
into the cup series all the way until I
retired that we nurtured and grew that
fan base we grew it and we helped grow
the sport I feel like that we did a lot
of things that we NASCAR drivers
typically didn't have the opportunity to
do to go mainstream and get into
publications like MTV Cribs or Rolling
Stone magazine and I did I know that I
had that key to the door because of the
budweiser relationship and we had a lot
of opportunities through that
relationship through Budweiser but I
felt good about what I did as a driver I
won more races than I ever thought I
would and I did not think that I was
gonna win the Daytona 500 in my life I
didn't think that I was gonna have the
success that I had on the track of
course never imagined what would happen
off the track the fans the the
opportunities to do those publications
and and things that people night late
night shows this you know I never
thought I would this would be my life so
I feel like we did a really good job
taking something that we probably didn't
deserve and making more out of it and
and it was a good ride man it was a lot
of fun well in him when you say that
obviously in the past tense so many of
your fans Dale are were disappointed to
learn that you were getting out of the
car obviously you were concerned about
your health your concussions and you
talked about it in racing to the finish
here you were this this is what
fascinating to me so you were riding
down symptoms you were feeling typing it
into your phone yeah when did you first
start doing that when you realized that
maybe I need to start documenting the
way I'm feeling yeah so I had a crash in
2012 and a couple wrecks that layered
two concussions together within a month
and gotten some pretty bad trouble
physically with that ended up at the
University of Pittsburgh Medical Center
with Mickey Collins Michael Collins who
works with the Pittsburgh Steelers and
the Penguins aside from seeing the
everyman kids housewives anyone who
suffered an injury like that but he's
specialists in in concussions and he has
a huge team around him and just an
incredible facility an incredible man
but I got put in front of him and that
you know when I was going through those
concussions in 2012 and he he helped me
get well getting my wife back fixed all
the problems I had what were the
problems that you were having in in that
at that time concussions are like
snowflakes every one you gets different
every time you get a concussion you
don't always have the same symptoms you
may have it may be taste emotions eyes
balance you emotion there's so many
things that the mind is it's a computer
you know and I know we assume at Luke
Kuechly gun got carted off the
concussion he was crying hysterically
couldn't control her like we thought
maybe he broke his leg or something no
he was concussed and you can't you can't
it's a switch like that crying that
emotion is a switch that flips on like a
broken faucet did you can't turn off and
so and that's the way all the symptoms
are cuz they just you know they're out
of control
but I had in that in at that time I was
dealing with fogginess basically like
the worst hangover he had all day every
day not going away you know and nausea
and some balance issues but mainly just
a fog feeling disconnected like I
couldn't hurt carry a conversation with
people I couldn't I couldn't enjoy the
moment or be in the moment a lot of
emotional things and short temper and
anxiety really really raging anxiety
going into complex environments with
busy things happening and lots of people
around just oh man it was just terrible
but he fixed that and we got well we're
going through that experience I thought
I was educated enough to manage it if it
happened again if I gotten in another
crash I called it a sub concussion if I
crashed and felt bad it go away in a
couple days and I would be fine and as
long as it wasn't any more serious than
that I didn't need to probably alert
Mickey or do anything
in case you know it was serious
I would document it when the crash would
happen on Sunday night I would write
down on these notes on my phone what I
felt I'd write down probably three or
four entries every day after that until
it would go away and you know and I
would race for a month or two without
any problems in crash again and have
that repeat that process and I did that
I had about 12 of those concussions and
in from 2012 to 2016
I suffered about 12 of those types of
concussions and it caught up with me I
got to where one day just out of nowhere
I had my like the last crash I had was
on June 12th in Michigan in 2016
four weeks later I I woke up one day and
I couldn't walk I couldn't stand up or
without I couldn't get out of this chair
without holding onto it out of the blue
just out of the blue I couldn't walk
across the room without holding on to
that table turned the corner he got
grabbed the wall and and any kind of
motion with my head up down all around
would would send me spinning and it came
out of nowhere I had no impact to link
it to the last crash was a month ago and
you know you think concussions are
immediately connected to an event sure
in that moment right whether or not they
don't always have to be they can cut you
know you can have these concussion
issues that's what tricks a lot of
people is these issues can kind of come
week C weeks after the crash or the
impact that you have the event you have
so that's what happened I just I put all
the you know I did this I beat myself up
for all these years trying to manage it
myself and I ended up with really really
debilitating symptoms balance my eyes
didn't work well I couldn't they call it
gaze stabilization so when I'd walk
across the room my eyes would sort of
have a hard time the room was shake you
know driving down the road in a car road
signs and cars around me or bouncing
around like crazy
you couldn't yeah it was you just said
to stare at the floor you couldn't ride
down the road in the car me and my wife
went to a tasting for our wedding and it
was a - it was
two and a half three hour trip round
trip and I just stared at the floorboard
the whole way in whole way home it was
just miserable and so anyways I'm find
myself back at Mickey Collins in
Pittsburgh and and we I had to get out
of the car Stan its head we were in the
middle of race season he's like you got
to stop and I had to take medication to
help my anxiety that was the first time
I'd ever really taken any medication for
my concussion symptoms but he gave me a
very robust package of treatment for
five months I was doing these exercises
physical exercises exercises on
computers for the visual stuff the
treatment that he gave me in 2016 was
completely 180 from what he gave me in
2012 meaning that they've learned so
much just in that short period of time
because you know we're kind of living in
this hole oh yeah discovery of what's
going on with CTE and what's what people
what athletes are dealing with and
changing the culture and while all this
is happening on the field and on the
racetrack scientists are now pushing and
pushing and pushing the research they're
also obviously having patience and
examples like myself to learn from and
more people are speaking up knowing that
they can go get treatment 2012 I didn't
know I could go to a doctor and I didn't
know I just thought you laid down and
let it rest off and let it go away like
a bruise well now me and everyone else
is learning that you can go to this
doctor you can go to a doctor get
treatment so we're all in like
hyperspeed learning treatment
discovering things understanding things
and it's amazing to be going through
that process but that's what the books
about the books about my missteps my
mistakes trying to manage it myself the
books about Mickey Mickey comes in
behind a lot of the conversation in the
book and backs up some of the things I'm
talking about or explains what I'm
saying the things I'm saying doing the
things I'm doing what we did to treat X
Y & Z so he's as much of the book as I
am which adds a lot of substance and and
credibility to the story and he writes
the foreword which is I think really
powerful coming from him and so all I
want to do really is to drive people to
Mickey there's a bunch of Mickey's in
this
world but I Mickey is the man I know and
I want to drive people to Mickey and
Pittsburgh that need his help whether
you're an athlete or a housewife or
plumber I don't care and you know if you
had a you know injury ten years ago
that's still giving you problems today
Mickey can help you and you don't have
you can have this I want people to have
the best quality life they can you know
that's really important for me becoming
a father and a newlywed and all those
things I've got any um retiring from
racing I've got this amazing opportunity
in front of me life you know in front of
me and so I want people to be able to
enjoy what I'm enjoying Dale Earnhardt
jr. of the book again racing to the
finish my story and is interesting you
say finish because as you just said you
you feel like you've got a new start
going on right now is life ahead of you
that you're working with NBC you're
doing a great job as a broadcaster right
now and as you mentioned you you've got
a six month old daughter i lo with your
your your your wife amy it if you have a
son or if you would like ila to race
would you would you be up for letting
your kids absolutely I would never
discourage anybody from racing playing
sports whatever that's not the message
the message is mace is is to make the
decision do you think you didn't make
the right time did not make the right
decisions absolutely not no when I got
hurt in 2012 initially and got help and
saw Mickey the next time I got hurt
months down the road six months or
whenever I should have went right back
to him and I tried to kite ride to I
tried to manage it myself and keep it to
myself and I did that for three or four
years until it caught up with me and I
couldn't hide it no longer so if you get
it if you have you know if you get it if
you get a nasty hit or a nasty fall and
you have these symptoms go to the doctor
get in front of a neurosurgeon to get
ahead of this issue or or just it's you
you do not want to risk managing this
yourself getting another injury in a
short period of time and dealing with
these symptoms down the road that you
don't have to deal with you don't have
to live with these you know these
annoying little
under right under the surface problems
that are going to be there and so yeah I
don't feel like that I handle that the
right way I didn't tell that story when
it was happening live you know and I
retired prematurely I know that I feel
that and I feel like my fans know that
and they're like what's going on why are
you quitting you know you're young you
know in terms of drivers you know I feel
you know I feel young I feel great and I
know my fans had a ton of questions as
to why why are you retiring why this
makes no sense well this book spells
everything out for them and the ones
that have read it that I've heard from
they're like now I get it
you know this man you know I did not
know this was all happening and I didn't
want to tell that story while I was
racing after I came back from the injury
in 2016 I ran one more season in 2017
and that was sort of my hey this is my
last year guys let's have some fun let's
enjoy it I didn't want to tell the story
and be talking about concussions that
entire final year I wanted to just love
you know love what I was doing and then
and get it all out of my system and
enjoy those last several laps oh you're
making the most your platform obviously
of your post you know racing career
doing your broadcasting in with NBC and
then writing a book like this which must
not have been easy for you to do it
wasn't fun to go back and relive a lot
of that stuff I was ashamed of some of
the things that I was going to be
telling people ashamed of the mistakes I
made my wife didn't even know about
these notes for a long time about in
your phone your tone yeah I got hit it
from everyone and my wife you know she
she knew something wasn't quite right at
certain points
she was always you know kind of you know
like is there something you need to tell
me after after each of these accidents
are you being totally truthful because
she would come to me and say you got
your you okay you know is your head okay
and I would always go yeah I think I'm
fine and you know brush it off so that
it was a it was tough to reveal the
truth but I think you have to tell the
whole story to have any credibility to
the story
and for the story to reach people it has
to be the whole story so and I felt like
my fans deserve that that truth man you
are authentic as they get man I'm
serious this is uh you know because when
you hear somebody retires earlier than
would be expected you think that it was
might have been a struggle sounds like
that this was an easy decision for you I
was he was an easy decision for me
because I didn't want to go through it
anymore plus with the broadcasting
opportunity it's been so seamless for me
had I not had that and I think I would
probably be missing it terribly but the
broadcasting gives me a great
opportunity to be involved in a sport
I'm at the track I'm talking racing I'm
a huge fan I was a fan first before I
became a driver so I just can go back to
doing that and when I watched those guys
race they're they're elite athletes
doing something very hard very
challenging
I respect the struggle of racing a car
for three and a half hours when it's one
hundred and forty hundred fifty degrees
inside the car I don't want anything to
do with that anymore well it's great to
see a Dale please whenever you're out
here in Los Angeles I'd love to have you
back in here we'll talk about your
Redskins too you can you can turn I am
we lost a great guard Brandon got a
couple yeah a couple of guys banged up
on the offensive line that's gonna be
difficult for us and our quarterback and
wide receivers just aren't working well
together for whatever reason defense is
doing Peterson's unbelievable yeah our
defensive lines great as draft picks
that we've got from Alabama doing a good
job that's right Kerrigan is being here
Kerrigan man exactly great to see you
Dale jr. check out his new book racing
to the finish that's available right now
at Dale jr. on Twitter as well as
Instagram the Rich Eisen show weekdays
at noon eastern on audience